hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're going to be talking about
the dead stream recap that just happened
today now the density of recap was kind
of short it was about 20 minutes of just
talking about certain box and stuff and
then 40 minutes of duals from players
that they flew out to their studio to
play some of these players consisted of
before on our fight club players on the
discord in some of the four Honor Flight
Academy discord as well there are some
pretty high level players it was more
matches alike warlord and TK some more
than Ken's a stuff warden and another
one knows is some lobby action it was
pretty nice it was very good to watch
some high-level play and what that looks
like anyway we're here to talk about the
dirksen buff so let's get right into
this the devastated that in one week
xbox will finally xbox and ps4 will
finally be getting the one point 05
update which I covered last week they
have it has yet to be released and it
will finally be released which is
everything I covered last we look I said
if you did not see that you can go check
the video home last week it covers
everything that's going to be in that
patch in the next two weeks pc will be
getting a new patch of one point 06 and
then the following we're after that xbox
and ps4 will beginning that same patch
new ornaments have been released if you
haven't played the game in a few days
you should know they're already in them
in the game I made a video yesterday and
what the ornaments look like you can go
check and the in the description below I
do have a link to my newest video my
oldest video just previous to this and
then they also stated that the season is
coming to an end and they stated that
the faction more the faction that wins
the faction war or season will get a
pretty hefty reward they never said what
what it is worth fighting for and then
the small chance that the Knights do win
the faction war and it becomes a tie the
they said that the affection with the
most amount of war assets will be the
winning faction of that season to
differentiate the type of the tiebreaker
one of the devs did state that they are
looking into wardens vortex moves the
way his shoulder bash the light attack
shoulder rush led the attack combo kind
of works they're going to be fixing some
of that later and they also said to the
Raiders going to be getting some box
that never did mention what they were
but they do but we do know that they are
getting some boss
I was really all they did talk about
like I stayed that there was like 20
minutes of just fly of these types of
patches and then 40 minutes of fighting
it was kind of useless I wish they did
talk more but that's going to be really
it though I hope you guys did enjoy if
you did please like the video if you're
new to this please subscribe and then
other than that guys will see you all
later and please help